you should absolutely start flirting
with broader content 100 it needs to be
part of your mix the first 50 pieces of
business content I made every comment
was [__] you stay in your lane wine boy
what the [__] do you know about business
I'm like Jesus Christ I was like that's
all I've been doing I just became Wine
Guy to you because of YouTube I'm like I
am business you need to be insane insane
about Facebook fan page output number
one the game is back at scale YouTube
shorts number two Tick Tock number three
you must dominate those three arbitrages
a day would you say ideal for per
platform and then there's Twitter and
Instagram and regular YouTube and Link
and Linkedin